in a recent stream I raised the question
how many of you haven't played demon
sauce and after a quick Twitter poll I
confirmed that 60% of my audience hasn't
played this incredible music from the
demon souls soundtrack accurately
represents my service at that fact
because my audience is entirely made up
of salsa cuter born fans and as sucky
born Souls fans know it's difficult to
play just one of these blood sucky souls
games and not touch the others too many
of us demon souls is the game that
started at all but as from software
continues iterating on its success new
players are entering the series at later
and later points and as new sequels are
created demon souls is being forgotten
locked not only behind playstation
exclusivity but also exclusivity in an
older console generation the PlayStation
3 which is exactly why it deserves a
remaster more than Dark Souls ever did
to be honest this was the first Souls
game they ever made and it could really
do with some quality of life changes
not to mention updated frame rates and
textures since this is also a game that
never got a PC release and let's be
honest it never will so there's no way
of experiencing these textures in higher
resolution nor frame rates at a stable
60 the closest you can get is emulation
and ps3 emulation has come a really long
way in recent years it's come so far in
fact that I bet you didn't even realize
this but the footage that you're seeing
is from the emulated version if you
don't own a ps3 this is an option but
please if you do end up going down this
route purchase the game as well it's 25
bucks even if you don't have a ps3 just
grab a physical version in store or a
digital version from Sony's website it's
the right thing to do Demon Souls takes
place in the age of the second scourge
the land of boletaria is enveloped by
fog and demons have taken over they're
enriching their own Souls with the souls
of humans many warriors venture into the
fog to figure out what's going on
but only one makes it out and his royal
knight named valor facts
fala facts tells of king allant who in
his lust for power awakened an elder
being called the old one the old one
back into the fog the demons and it also
unlocked the mystical soul arts which is
a tool that you may choose to use though
you do risk becoming one of the demons
that you've set out to destroy this
isn't the first time the scourge has
happened it is called the second scourge
after all and if someone doesn't enter
the fog and defeat the demons it might
be the last scourge I have a short
series of Demon Souls videos if you want
to learn more and I really should make
more because Demon Souls is special I
find from software games really hard to
rank because they all have strengths and
weaknesses that the others don't but
nothing from dark souls to sekito beats
demon souls in terms of atmosphere and
ambience in my opinion I mean just
listen to this clip
that's right atmosphere in five seconds
of latria is thicker than in the
entirety of aerosol dungeon the rattling
of bars the screams of the prisoners the
piercing chime of those mind flayer
bells it's legitimately chilling and
depressive when you go through here and
what makes it genius is that this is a
feeling that is reinforced by the
gameplay itself this is one of the few
areas in souls that still intimidates me
even though I've played through it tens
of times by now there's this gameplay
loop in this section which has you
peering in to cells for loot and to
avoid enemies yet the real goal of this
Pettitt 'iv horizontal process is to
dull your awareness of the occasional
vertical deathtrap that's lurking in the
shadows furthermore every damn corridor
looks the same and the keys are placed
so far from the doors that they unlock
that it forces you to retrace your steps
and double back a process that masks
your sense of progression through this
place so even though you're outside of
these cells you feel like a prisoner and
there's no sound more terrifying to a
prisoner than this aggravated warning
bell of the mind flayers it's an enemy
that can easily one-shot even the most
accomplished player to be honest if you
let down your guard and pretty much
every area in Demon Souls has this much
character enemies
sound effects level design gameplay
they're all there and they all make the
worlds feel lived in and distinct
there's boletaria castle with this theme
of archers who attack you at range at
the same time soldiers attack you in
melee they're coordinated by contrast
there's the stone Fang tunnels with
these resilient miners who can be
dangerous but who usually barely pay you
in
tenshun they're just in the background
focusing on their work instead and if
you accidentally aggro them then it's
pretty rough
there's the shrine of storms which has
this visual aesthetic to it that's
actually never been replicated in
subsequent games it's this level that
makes you sort of fear the open sky and
it forces you to listen to noises coming
from the sky so that you can avoid
javelins coming your way and then
there's the next level of latria which
is one of my favorites it has you
standing and fighting on these narrow
platforms against these gargoyles that
are seeing you and all the while you're
fighting to the beat of this enormous
heart that looms over you the entire
time and who can forget Oh JEE
Blighttown as opposed to other swamp
areas it's even broader with no real
landmarks in it the rain is pouring down
so hard you can barely see and later on
you get to these hovels where the flies
are so thick in the air that you
actually kind of do feel bad for
invading this place and the cool thing
about these levels is that you can play
them in virtually any order which is a
design decision I think helped the devs
fully realize their vision for these
areas because they didn't have to design
them so that they blend in to one
another you know additionally being able
to access most of the game from the
get-go vastly expands the character
builds that you can go for so to build
this sorcerer built for example I went
to one of the most difficult sections of
the shrine of storms and defeated the
skeletons with my bare fists because
that uses blunt damage and then I got
this powerful curved blade which in turn
allowed me to tackle different sections
of the game like latria where I could
quickly unlock Soul ray which is this
piercing powerful main spell that can
carry you the rest of the game basically
actually I feel like the magic and Demon
Souls was really ahead of its successes
in many ways yes it's very overpowered
but man I'd actually prefer that to how
weak and onions
but magic kind of fields in the sequel's
manner can regenerate over time here and
also when you use consumables which
feels more natural in my opinion plus
Demon Souls magic can be cast really
quickly and many spells can be used
while you're moving so this led to
really fast-paced PvP alas the servers
have been taken offline now which is
another reason a remaster would go down
really well I particularly enjoyed how
magic switched up my experiences with a
lot of the bosses my fight with the
armored spider became this long ranged
battle of timing and boss fights that
required stealth were made more
interesting
thanks to spells like cloak which hides
your presence I think the reason that
magic interfaces well with Demon Souls
bosses is because the bosses here are
far more gimmicky than in the sequels
and I absolutely don't mean that in a
bad way I just mean that the bosses here
in this game have more overt strengths
and weaknesses than in the sequels
bosses in Dark Souls and Beyond largely
come down to timing reflexes and skill
which don't get me wrong is still an
amazing experience but bosses and demon
souls are more of a puzzle they're
difficult in the beginning and then
easier when you figure out how to solve
it the end result of this is boss
designs that are incredibly memorable
and they have a ton of character to them
like the old hero who attacks you based
on the sounds you make or the fools Idol
who conjures mirror versions of herself
or made in Australia who barely fights
back at all relying instead on her brave
knight to take you down instead every
single boss is like this pretty much and
I would rant and rave about every one of
them but I'd pray spoil your experiences
if you hadn't played
the music in these fights is amazing too
most of them include choirs and they're
really orchestral arrangements that do
stand out from songs in subsequent
titles everyone who gets addicted to
souls games usually has a boss but they
struggled against for hours right and I
want to hear about what yours was in the
comments back then mine was flame loca
he's one of the few bosses in Demon
Souls that requires really
straightforward mechanical skill to beat
he's aggressive to the point where you
can't abuse spam healing which is a
problem in Demon Souls and there's lava
on the floor to watch out for and he
powers up as the fight goes on making it
so that if you get greedy at the end you
get punished I think I ended up having
such a hard time back in the day that I
ended up coming back to the game later
and rolling a new character with this
focus in mind to defeat flame Locker so
I picked up a heavy flame resistant
shield in the first level and I
completely Specht into strength just so
I could carry this huge shield and have
a really easy time against the boss
demon souls in general has more RPG
elements it has exploitable damage types
like flame damage and blunt damage seem
to make more of a difference and there
are way more varied upgrade materials
and also there's inventory management
which some may like some may dislike I
think most people hate the fact that in
Demon Souls a common occurrence is not
being able to carry a loot on the ground
and having to discard something that's
pretty frustrating and I think back then
I also didn't know how world tendency
worked so I probably made my flame
lurker fight way way harder so for those
of you who don't know demon souls have
this insane death penalty mechanic
whereby enemies in a stage would become
more dangerous and do more damage every
time that you died in that level in
human form the only way around this was
not to die or you could play in phantom
form at 50% health so that you wouldn't
risk making your area harder if you did
die which was a trade-off that most
players were happy with because it
stopped their difficulty spiraling out
of
the fact that they put this in is such a
brave decision to put such a punishing
mechanic in the first Souls game no less
during its development Demon Souls
actually became known internally as a
failed project until hid otaku Miyazaki
took the reins he went on to say this
great quote he said I figured if I could
find a way to take control of the game I
could turn it into anything I wanted
best of all if my ideas failed nobody
would care it was already considered a
failure so this led to a lot of risks
like world tendency being taken and
while the game certainly wasn't a
success at launch
there was this word-of-mouth effect that
eventually spread of this deep punishing
game from Japan and then Namco Bandai
and Atlas eventually decided to publish
it in the West I know I heard about it
from word of mouth I heard stories about
this final boss that could drain the
levels from you that you'd accumulated
throughout the game and I thought damn
that sounds so metal so what is the
actual likelihood of a remaster early
this year there was this interview with
Game Informer where Nia's Aki mentioned
that a remaster was possible but only if
it was a studio that really loved the
original work and really put their heart
and soul into realizing it again then
that's something I would enjoy he goes
on to cite this discomfort with looking
back on his previous works but he says
that I understand that there are many
users and many players and fans out
there who really loved demons so if
that's something they could accomplish
with a studio that loved the work then
yeah I'd be okay with that
of course this all relies on Sony too he
says you'd have to see what they are
thinking about it and it seems like a
no-brainer right as I feel like a
remaster would offer something valuable
to those looking to play it again but
then they could also engage millions of
new players with this millions of people
don't own a ps3 but they have started
playing from software games in the past
few years
whether on PC or Xbox or even ps4
considering that from software have a
good relationship with Sony assumedly
blood-borne sold really well
and that the ps5 is looming in 2020 a
remonster would pull the entire souls
community into the PS 5 ecosystem
similar to what they did with
blood-borne I thought about starting a
petition for this and while I'm
convinced that there's this unbridled
desire from software fans that would
make a petition successful I don't know
if I feel comfortable putting that kind
of pressure on from software yet ask me
again in a few years because I really
can't imagine a remaster never being
made so for now I hope that this video
at least helps the 60% of you who
haven't played demon souls kind of
understand why it's a work of art and
why it has such a cult following - those
of you who have played demon souls
please share something you'd loved about
the game whether it's a location a boss
or an experience down in the comments
below or maybe use the hashtag des
remaster on Twitter if you want to get
trendy with it and to Sony please it's
free real estate before I end this video
I want to show off the Sennheiser PC 37
X is this really good budget headset
that's currently $30 off if you use the
link in the description and it's a
product I was already recommending to
friends even before crop reached out to
me I used to use drop calm way back when
it was still called mass drop and I
always liked their collaborations with
big brands because they tend to clean up
their designs and also offer a cheaper
price on top of that this clean matte
black headset is no exception
so first up it has an open back design
which I personally prefer and use over
closed back headphones open-back
headphones prevent heat buildup they
afford a more natural sort of sound
which is great for editing and you can
actually hear sounds that are around you
while you're gaming or listening to
music since I've been playing demon
souls all week there were moments in
game in latria in particular where
having good surround sound just saved my
life being able to track enemies behind
me
and also if you want to adjust that
volume the headphones also come with a
volume slider on the right ear cup which
is something you'll come to swear by
once you've gotten use to it one thing
that does usually bother me with
headsets is that they often skimp out on
the microphone quality because usually
if you think about it it's your friends
hearing the microphone not the user so
manufacturers often let it slide however
one of the best selling points of these
headphones is that the mic quality is
way better than its competitors at this
price point which as you can hear now
has lots of body and a detail to it that
is only enhanced by the inbuilt noise
canceling the PC 37 X punches way above
its weight for the price point so check
it out in the description below if
you're in the market for this kind of
thing thank you to drop for sponsoring
me and letting me try my hand at being a
tech youtuber it was actually a lot of
fun filming something completely
different like this so I appreciate the
opportunity but thank you for watching
and I'll see you next time
[Music]